welcome to this video against quorum ocm
going fo again naked lots of French's
yeah some of they don't play five that
much a bit surprised I thought I would
have gotten I would get more of those
ponds eonni puts yani openings but I
really don't don't get that so um we are
again in a French defence and I think
actually this is something that I have
played with black at one point Bishop g5
maybe looks kind of healthy Bishop e7 is
an interesting sideline for black it's
very difficult here for wise to keep the
pawn oh ok b6 so ok I'm just pushing
this if I take them sees fatigue and c6
if a cheeky always has pretty pretty
decent counterplay and still wonder
language c 6 cm d for Bishop a 6 is
embarrassing so maybe this is just c6
okay so look see one I have hard time to
believe that
an edge that this is compensation here
you can also just play night to deform
if i take c 5 Queenie 3 equals G 4 I
guess d for Queenie form maybe not quick
enough there to get c 5 I can just go 94
I don't know I just overlooked that d3
is hanging ok I need to break I need to
break me to get you to break here ah
notes you put I mean just blundered this
pawn and one move just and in a position
where white is probably much much better
already Wow
and his position was completely
unplayable for black never cannot allow
pawn to c6 and all that stuff never ever
and came but it's probably still not
that bad I still have the ponder so a 30
BD 3a 3b form if I go a tree first you
might play a form
it's still excellent for white I really
don't see his counter place till i
blundered the porn for absolutely
nothing but but what is he doing against
this a 3 be fined over
94 text the a poor now this this thing
maybe
so maybe night to d2 first takes Queen
takes keeps the whole thing together and
if he goes night see if I have now
before it's going to work I get in b5
yeah i think it's i think it's okay i
think it's okay a knight c5 b4 and b5 is
coming now I think it's okay it's bishop
on a six is pretty useless piece them
yeah this is the only slight hope there
maybe just FYI keep this and keep this
only five not ideal but still maybe I
should have taken first no like that
probably doesn't matter much so here I
don't think he cannot even attack the e5
pawn
the idea is just really b4 b5 and
support to support the porn yeah but
let's not let's not be I can take is six
at some moment maybe anyway I just play
those those slowish moves now because
unless I'm blundering material here I
will win with b4 b5 just have to keep
things control under control here so
King King to e3 his super safe
so this is established and now I just
need to get rooks traded rook a to look
F to probably it's got Luke f1 so let's
think for a moment down you can't move
much maybe doing like this now look at
two and rook f2
check
okay so let's see now can I go see seven
and rooks is six this winning wins a bit
of material down
probably wins probably does times make
it better here I wonder don't see it now
that isn't it isn't so clear
I mean at least I hoped for something
even more more decisive Roxy's 6 no
Bishop e7 don't do that let's get all of
this black forfeits aren't I and you can
see that I was so much ahead on time now
that that that that wasn't good
technical play from here that should be
very easy but wow you must be joking the
engine gives black a slight advantage I
can't stop laughing what I have a
protected passer on c6 I don't believe
that one bit ok now it goes to equal at
least it gives rook d 85 yeah ok that's
a point actually this is not as clear as
it should have been I mean the distance
is true really so look the one here by
that a form yeah i mean the biggest
biggest issue is i just gave away d
three or four absolutely nothing yet
such as such a this is just crazy I
absolutely did not see that the porn
hangs down and well let's say I take and
then do this or something here here this
is just excellent for wide
now or here in the first place I can do
this Bishop a six and just protect the
pawn this is just winning for a while
yeah I just have this pawn extra and I
get in ultimately I get in this a 4b
find his Knight has to leave and it's
over giving away g3 is just so crazy and
I just need a break here I think I mean
why this is still looking good here I
had before I even okay that was stronger
I didn't see that here that this is
hanging so he has to move the bishop and
this is this is very easy now ok so now
this is this is getting getting
difficult of course yeah 96 Weiss is so
strong I didn't I saw that but I didn't
see anything here ok so like this he
doesn't even have a check here yeah okay
and I'm threatening this so that was the
easy winner 96 yeah I wanted to keep
everything under control and even
calculate that move I just thought that
this is an automatic win but it doesn't
seem to be the case the engine is just
and not leaving that at all oopsie one
that's very very difficult to understand
everything so auntie em a try to okc
seven was winning why away because now
rooks is six ok attacking with two rocks
is stronger I only saw that idea later
after the the rook track but ok the
engine also gives this as a win so this
is at least a little bit reassuring
check and now can you form
but it also wins rook h6 was strong yeah
stronger than II 6mm ok Knight a5 was
better than the capture yeah but is the
winner tonight f5 year still ok America
yet no time whatsoever but it does so
feared feels a very very shaky okay well
thanks for watching